in many challenges personal and
professional we are held back by the
crippling thought that people like us
couldn't possibly triumph given what we
know of ourselves how reliably stupid
anxious gauche crude vulgar and dull we
really are we leave the possibility of
success to others because we don't seem
to ourselves to be anything like the
sort of people we see lorded around us
faced with responsibilities or prestige
we quickly become convinced that we are
simply imposters like an actor in the
role of a pilot wearing the uniform and
making sunny cabin announcements while
utterly incapable of even starting the
engines it can feel easier simply not to
try the root cause of the imposter
syndrome is a hugely unhelpful picture
of what other people are really like we
feel like imposters not because we're
uniquely flawed but because we fail to
imagine how deeply flawed everyone else
must necessarily also be beneath a more
or less polished surface the imposter
syndrome has its roots far back in
childhood specifically in the powerful
sense children have that their parents
are really very different from them to a
four year old it's incomprehensible that
their mother was once their age and
unable to drive a car tell the plumber
what to do decide other people's
bedtimes and go on planes with
colleagues the golfing status appears
absolute and unbridgeable the child's
passionate loves pouncing on the sofa
Pingu Toblerone have nothing to do with
those of adults who like to sit at a
table talking for hours when they could
be running about outside and drink beer
which tastes of rusty metal we start out
in life with a very strong impression
that other people especially competent
and admirable other people are really
not like us at all this childhood
experience dovetails with a basic
feature of the human condition we know
ourselves from the inside but we know
others only from the outside so we're
constantly aware of all our anxieties
doubts and idea seized yet all we know
of others is what they happen to do and
tell us which is a far narrower and more
edited source of information
we're often left to conclude that we are
isolated at the more freakish and
revolting end of human nature far from
it which is failing to imagine that
others are of course every bit as
disturbed as we are without knowing
exactly what it is that troubles or
rack's another outwardly very impressive
person we can be sure that it will be
something we might not know exactly what
they regret but there will be agonizing
feelings of some kind we won't be able
to say exactly what kind of unusual
sexual kink obsesses them but there will
be one and we can know this because
vulnerabilities and compulsions cannot
be curses that have just ascended upon
us uniquely they are universal features
of human mental equipment the solution
to the impostor syndrome lies in making
a crucial leap of faith the leap that
other's minds must work in basically
much the same way as ours do everyone
must be as anxious uncertain and wayward
as we are it's a leap of faith because
we just have to accept that the majority
of what we feel and are especially the
more shameful unmentionable sides will
have a corollary in each and every one
of us one of the tasks that works of art
should ideally accomplish is to take us
more reliably into the minds of people
we're intimidated by in order to show us
the more average muddled and fretful
experiences that they have that way we
would be helped to understand that we're
not barred by our vulnerabilities from
doing what they do that's what the
philosopher Montaigne writing in the
16th century was attempting to do when
he playfully informed his readers in
plain French that Kings and philosophers
[ __ ] and so dude ladies more Taine's
point is that for all the evidence that
exists about this [ __ ] we might not
guess that these people ever had to
squat on a toilet we never see
distinguished types doing this while of
course we are immensely well-informed
about
our own digestive activities and
therefore we build up a sense that
because we have crude and sometimes
rather desperate bowels we can't be
philosophers kings or ladies and that if
we set ourselves up in these roles we
would just be imposters more Taine's
example is a neat one because despite
the lack of evidence we know that these
exalted people must of course excrete in
exactly the same way we do so with
Montagnes guidance we're invited to take
on a Seine a sense of what grand
powerful and beautiful people are really
like
but the real target isn't just an under
confidence about bodily functions this
point extends into the psychological
arena to more tane might also have said
that Kings philosophers and ladies are
racked by self-doubt and feelings of
inadequacy sometimes bump into doors and
have weird lustful thoughts about
members of their own families
furthermore instead of considering only
the big figures of 16th century France
we could update this example and refer
to CEOs corporate lawyers news
presenters and successful startup
entrepreneurs they too can't cope feel
they might buckle under pressure and
look back on certain decisions with
shame and regret no less than [ __ ]
such feelings are not what separates us
from them
our inner frailties don't cut us off
from doing what they do if we were in
their roles we'd not be imposters we'd
simply be normal making a leap of faith
around what other people are really like
helps us to humanize the world it means
that whenever we encounter a stranger
we're not really encountering a stranger
we're in fact encountering someone who
is in spite of the surface evidence to
the contrary in basic ways very much
like us
and that therefore nothing fundamental
stands between us and the possibility of
responsibility success and fulfillment
you